نشاهد هذه الصور مباشره من العاصمه
الاسبانيه مدريد لفرحه الجمهور المغربي
والعربي بتاهل المغرب الى ربع نهائي كاس
العالم اذن الجاليه المغربيه والعربيه
تحتفل بانتصار منتخبنا على اسبانيا في
العاصمه مدريد
اذن وبهذا يصبح المغرب اول بلد عربي يصل
الى دور الثمانيه نستمع قليلا الى الصوت
الطبيعي وهذه الفرحه
[تصفيق]
يعني
مشاهدينا المنتخب الاسباني ليس منتخبا
عاديه كان يعني كان هناك توقعات بان يصل
الى النهائي وربما يفوز بهذه البطوله
ببطوله كاس العالم لكن المغرب فجاه الجميع
وافرح العرب جميعا كما افرحت قبل ذلك
المملكه العربيه السعوديه العرب بفوزها
على الارجنتين وتونس ايضا اذا يعني كاس
العالم هذا العام مميز بالنسبه للعرب في
كل شيء بهذه الانتصارات المفاجاه
ايضا بانه لاول مره يقام على ارض عربيه
نذكر بانه اشرف حكيمي الذي سجل اليوم هو
مولود في اسبانيا وخريج اكاديميه ريال
مدريد وهي كانت الركله الحاسمه في شباك
الحارس الاسباني اوناي سيمون بعد فشل
لاعبي اسبانيا في تسجيل ايا من ركلاتهم
اذن ونحن نشاهد هذه الصور
المباشره من مدريد يحتفل المغاربه هناك
بفوزهم على اسبانيا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
كما يعني تعلمون العديد من اللاعبين
المنتخب المغربي هم اصلا لاعبون في
منتخبات او في فرق اسبانيا اصلا وبالتالي
يعلمون
ربما تكتكات المنتخب الاسباني ولديهم
خبرات عاليه